foreign
[Music]
they were promoting that you can attend
more than one game in a single game you
can attend all games in the single game
the stadiums are close to each other
this idea kept growing in my head until
they started selling the tickets and I
started buying the tickets and they said
the theater I'm gonna do what I'm gonna
do it
[Music]
today and the time and the location
and it takes two photos at least
on the 4 to 10 videos in the game and
force them to the Guinness
[Music]
I bought this cap it's for the World Cup
and uh I'm counting the numbers of the
games I'm attending this is my 10th game
today today is my 10th game and uh I
hope it's gonna be filled with with
these lines
[Music]
I have my butterfly here
this keeps the water cold and my t-shirt
when I change after
very much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s are close to each other the next World
Cup is going to be in three countries
imagine traveling around and in these
big countries like the United States
maybe have a uh six hours flight between
the stadium
[Music]
[Applause]